>> Cosmos is yours.
Come with me.
>> Neal Degrass Tyson, I was
going to wear that exact tie.
>> No you were not.
You are lying.
>> I promise you, I do not have
a tie like that in my closet.
>> I have 110 ties.
Each one is uniquely capturing
in the up verse as imagined as
felt through the eyes of an
artist.
>> I want to start with your
latest book "Story messenger."
In your book, you use the device
of saying what would an alien
say?
>> Yes.
>> If they came here to Earth
from outer space.
>> Yeah.
>> And they saw our wars, our
politics, as you say, our
inability to distinguish fact
from opinion.
So what do you think said alien
would say?
>> So the alien comes upon
Earth, beautiful blue marble
orbiting the sun and there is
ocean and land and clouds and
learn there is a species that
spread itself across all the
land.
Oh, that's a very productive
productive,
successful species and come down
and say wait a minute, that same
species has drawn lines on this
otherwise continuous set of land
masses and these lines you can't
cross them unless you have
special papers, not only that,
they have divided themselves by
who they worship, who their skin
color is, what their -- how they
dress, where resources are and
where they're not.
On a level where they will even
commit violence, even all out
war.
>> But we do have real
differences, serious differences
between nations, between
political parties.
Are we just supposed to say from
a cosmic perspective they don't
matter?
>> No, no.
In fact, the differences enrich
the plurality of a nation,
especially a free nation.
I don't want to get rid of
differences.
I want to get rid of differences
that are not different.
You think different because you
dug your heels into some opinion
that is malformed based on what
you think is true.
That's different from us
agreeingbjectively
true and sitting down saying
what do you think of this?
You share your point of view as
do I.
That's interesting.
I haven't thought about it that
way.
Is there a way to resolve this?
>> You have carved out a unique
place for yourself in our
intellectual life these days.
And I think, I don't know if
you'll object to this, I would
describe it as the pop
scientist.
Here you are on one of your many
shows, cosmos possible world.
Take a look.
>> Every month represents about
a billion years.
Every day represents nearly 40
million years.
That first day of the cosmic
year began with the big bang.
Almost 14 billion years ago.
Nothing really happened in our
neck of the universe until about
3 billion years later.
March 15th of the cosmic year.
When our milky way galaxy began
to form.
>> How did you decide on this
role and do you get push back
and I say this advisedly serious
scientist.
>> That pop scientist role had
already been carved by Carl
Sagan and whatever blood on the
tracks that left, I remember
hearing about this that he was
chastised by colleagues for
appearing on "Tonight show" with
Johnny Carson and had reach into
the tax paying public so at some
level we have a duty, if not an
obligation to bring some of that
back to the public and yeah,
when I'm writing a back, I'm not
doing the research paper.
Right?
So there is a tradeoff often in
that.
But no, I still have strong
roots into the research
community.
>> You were involved in the
effort to demote Pluto.
You even appeared on my favorite
science show "Big bang theory".
>> Oh.
>> Here it is.
[ Laughter ]
>> I'm quite familiar with Dr.
Tyson.
He's responsible for the
demotion of Pluto.
I liked Pluto.
Ergo, I do not like you.
>> I didn't demote Pluto.
That was a vote of the union.
>> If IFS and buts were nuts,
we'd all have a merry Christmas.
>> I can't act.
>> I thought you did well.
>> Did I do okay?
>> Yeah.
>> Is it true you got hate mail
for dissing Pluto?
>> Yeah.
I got a file cabinet this deep
from third graders.
>> Third grade, I learned how
you can tell the planets from
their distance from the sun,
Mary's violet eyes make John
stay up nights period.
Period.
Pluto.
Now there's no period.
>> So deal with it.
[ Laughter ]
I'm just saying.
>> All right.
In a minute, why is Pluto not a
planet?
>> Pluto's orbit is
significantly tipped out of the
plane of orbits of other
planets.
More than half of Pluto's volume
is comprised of ice.
If you brought Pluto to where
Earth is now, heat from the sun
would evaporate that ice and
grow a tail.
That's not behavior for a
planet.
>> Do you believe that there is
life out there somewhere?
>> I would say that if there
weren't life, it would be
astonishing.
If -- given how common our
ingredients are and how quickly
life took place and how many
planets are orbiting the stars.
>> What about aliens and ufos.
>> Any life is aliens.
You mean are antennas and ray
guns?
>> Anything without a cell.
>> Something that could land in
a spaceship?
Could be out there.
There is no evidence that would
convince an authentic skeptic
that we've been visited and I
can tell you this, these fuzzy
monocramtic tick tacks that show
up on Navy restricted air space
in our own atmosphere, by the
way, you've seen the high
resolution images from a
telescope we parked a million
miles from Earth called the
James Webb space telescope
looking at the edge of the
universe and the best you have
of visiting aliens is a fuzzy
tick tack?
You got to do better than that
if you convince an astro
physist.
>> You go to the planetarium,
changed your mind, why?
>> Sometimes I wonder if I grew
up on a farm somewhere I
wouldn't be as star struck as I
was because there I am a kid
having grown up until the bronx.
>> Right.
>> You sit in a chair.
The lights dim.
The stars come out and more
stars than I ever seen in my
life.
A hoax for sure.
I know how many stars are in the
night sky.
There is six visible from the
bronx.
That was the night sky.
No one in New York City has any
kind of relationship with the
night sky.
>> It's true.
When you go out into the real
world, it's like what are all
those lights?
>> What are all those lights?
There they dim the lights and
I'm struck by it.
Whereas had I seen that every
night of my life, this would be,
of course, this was just the
night sky.
So this -- it hit me.
So I don't think I chose the
universe, I think the universe
chose
>> You talk about your journey.
You used this phrase as the path
of most resistance.
A young black kid from the bronx
becoming an astrophysicist.
How tough was that path?
How important do you think it
has been for people of color to
see you in the place that you
occupy?
>> I will invert that and say,
how important is it for white
people to see me where I am?
That's a way more important
force operating, especially if
that is the community that
wields resources and
opportunities.
And if you see a black homeless
person in the street and you
never saw a black academically
achieved other human being, you
are prone to say, that's just
their lot in life.
But now, you will see me and you
will see the black homeless
person, and you have to deal
with that.
Oh, my gosh, there but for the
lack of opportunity goes --
>> A lot of people?
>> A lot of people.
I want to put that up front.
It was the path of most
resistance because I was also
physically fit and athletic.
You see a black person who is
that, particularly in the day,
you should be an athlete.
That just simply fulfills
people's bin they would put you
because they have never seen
your kind do anything else.
My father, who is active with
the civil rights movement, he
had way worse life encounters
than I did, dealing with
society.
He was never bitter.
He said, these people don't know
better.
So I have carried that with me
ever since.
I have never been bitter.
It just is.